and programming languages and uh some of
those topics
include uh the analysis of asynchronous
mixed synchrony systems uh model
checking
um and software verification and uh more
recently
on constrained counting and sampling
in saturn smt problems um
and and most you know over the last five
years his he and his group have been
working on this topic of boolean
functional synthesis
which uh they've written a sequence of
really exciting papers on
and so i'm really delighted today that
super thick will be talk sharing these
results with us
um on a counter example guided repair in
boolean functional synthesis
thank you sanjit uh am i audible
yes we can hear you okay great uh
so thanks sanjit for the kind
introduction and uh
and welcome everybody to uh this talk on
counter example guided repair in boolean
functional synthesis
uh this is joint work with uh s
akshay ajit john and shithil shah
i also want to say that uh some of you
may have attended a couple of other
talks that i have given
as part of the simon's program on
boolean functional synthesis
so uh while the stock is the focus of
the stock is
uh different from what i have covered in
the other talks
you know some of the motivation and
stuff uh are obviously similar
so hopefully uh there will be enough uh
for you to
uh stay tuned till end of the talk okay
so uh so here is a very generic view of
synthesis
which is that we have a specification
given as a logical formula
and uh this could be in any logic
for example it could be in temporal
logic and
we have some inputs of the system
denoted in blue and some outputs of the
system denoted in red
and we have a system to be designed
which must satisfy the specification
so the goal of synthesis automated
synthesis
is to synthesize the system such that
the specification is satisfied but there
is an interesting twist here that
sometimes uh specifications are such
that
you know you may not be able to satisfy
it for all possible inputs
and so we say that well you synthesize a
system such that
you know the specification is satisfied
whenever it is possible
and i i'm shortly going to give you some
examples of this
so really what we want to synthesize are
you know i mean the system has
outputs uh which must
be synthesized as some functions of the
inputs but then
it need not depend on just the inputs it
can depend on the history of
you know what inputs and what outputs
have shown up it can depend on some
internal state which could be
summarizing this history
and so on so really we need to design
the outputs y
as functions of perhaps the history
and the state of the system such that
the specification is satisfied
so just to be a little bit more concrete
here is a specific instantiation of
of this generic picture where i have a
temporal specification
and this is for a very simple arbiter
where i'm saying that you know these x1
and x2s can be viewed as requests and y1
and y2s
y2s can be viewed as grants for a shared
resource
so this is a simple specification which
says that
if indeed there was a request then at
some
if there was a request from you know
requester
one at some point in time in the future
uh
requested one should be granted the
resource and similarly for requester 2
and of course the resource cannot be
granted to both of them simultaneously
and in this case you know we might be
interested in synthesizing the outputs
uh as a function of because clearly
there's some history involved over here
i need to know whether uh you know
somebody had requested
so that in the future i have to grant
so i have to synthesize the outputs as a
function of the state
uh which summarizes the history of uh
the inputs and the outputs
now uh a very uh you know popular
and very effective way of solving these
kinds of temporal
synthesis problems is to use what is
called the winning region calculations
so you basically find out
uh the state space you know
of as different inputs and different
outputs are coming what is the possible
state space you can have
so here i have just tried to draw some
you know hypothetical state space not
necessarily for this temporal
specification
so there are states from which the
inputs can come
and you have no control over these
inputs so these are the blue arrows
and then there are states from which the
outputs have to be generated
and you do have control on how how you
want to generate the outputs
so these are labeled by the these are
shown by the red arrows over here
and a winning region is basically a set
of states
such that no matter what the environment
does no matter what kind of inputs come
it is always possible for you to satisfy
the temporal specifications so
in this particular case let us say that
these states shaded green
uh constitute the winning region and if
you notice very carefully that
you know if a state so let us say this
state and there are two
possible ways in which the inputs can
come
but no matter which way it comes so for
example if it comes this way you can
generate this output and stay within the
green states
if it comes this way you can generate
this output and stay within the green
states
and so on and so forth for the other
states
so so this style of temporal synthesis
basically says that okay let's first
find the winning region and the state
transition
graph and then we need to synthesize a
winning strategy
which helps ensure that we always stay
within the winning region because as
long as we are within the winning region
we know for sure that we can satisfy the
temporal specification
okay and uh this is actually a very uh
popular and effective way of
doing temporal synthesis but you know if
you look at the
core of this there are these two steps
one is calculating the winning region
uh which involves some kind of
reachability analysis on the state space
and the other is synthesizing this
winning strategy to stay within the
winning region
and what does this mean so once you have
this state space and
in particular if you have a symbolic
representation of the state space and
the state transitions
we are basically saying that from every
state
i should output y such that the next
state that i get
from my current state and when i'm
outputting y
is within the winning region so if wind
region denotes a predicate which depend
which denotes the set of green states
and if next state is
the transition relations so that uh you
know given a state
uh and y it tells me what the next state
is and if both of these are symbolically
represented
i just have one predicate here which i
should try to ensure that it always
evaluates to true so i have to
synthesize
y such that from every state this
predicate i mean this this entire
composed predicate evaluates to true
the interesting thing to note here is
that i mean although we started off with
the temporal specification and which was
used to get this winning region but
after we have obtained this winning
region
and when we are trying to synthesize the
winning strategy there are no temporal
operators here if we can symbolically
represent the winning region
and the next state transition relation
uh
and the other important thing to note
here is that it is not necessary that
from
every state you can synthesize a y which
will
get you within the winning region so for
example uh you know this unshaded
uh uncolored state here is such that no
matter what why you choose you're not
going to come within the winning region
and so this is you know a kind of uh
important property of a lot of synthesis
problems we try to solve
but the specification may not be
satisfiable you know in all cases
but nevertheless whenever it is possible
to be satisfied we would like to
generate the outputs
such that uh you know our our
specification temporal or otherwise is
satisfied
uh here is uh another instantiation of
the same
template and here uh i have a bit vector
specification
uh saying that there is a single input x
there are two outputs y one and y two
and i want x to be the product of y one
and y two the n bit
vector multiplication unsigned integer
multiplication
and i do not want y one or y two to be
the the vector representing the constant
1.
so uh you know if i view this problem
once again over here
i have to synthesize y1 and y2 as
functions of x
once again no temporal operators and you
know this clearly means that y 1 and y 2
have to be non-trivial factors of this
integer x
and once again this is not always
satisfiable in particular if x is prime
because we have required that neither y
1 nor y 2 should be 1.
and of course if i could find an
efficient solution for this this would
break cryptosystems
this is just to say that this problem is
not easy
okay so having said that uh
you know here is the formal definition
of boolean function synthesis
i guess in both of the previous examples
we saw that
you know after a certain point we are
really looking at specifications which
have no temporal operators
and which may not always be satisfied
and so
we're just saying let's focus on these
boolean specifications
on input and output variables and i want
to synthesize these boolean functions
for each of the outputs such that for
every input if it is possible to provide
values for the output such that the
specification can be satisfied
then it is indeed the case that the
specification is satisfied
with these functions substituted for the
outputs and
uh you know i would like to reiterate
here that
this form is also used for solving
temporal synthesis
once you have calculated the winning
region and once you're focused on
uh just generating the winning strategy
so so although we are talking about
boolean function synthesis
it has applications for reactive control
synthesis for example
uh and these functions fj are also
called scolum functions
for uh the outputs in the specification
and uh you know we've already looked at
this that it may be the case that for
some x's i may not have any y's
but still the problem is interesting as
long as there are other x's for which i
can find
y such that the specification holds
and you know for every x for which there
exists a y i should get the right thing
i should get the right value of y and if
i give you x and f x
it's actually easy to check whether
there exists a y such that phi of x y is
true because
uh you know from this definition i know
that
you know in order to find out whether
exists why phi of x y is true i can just
substitute the functions
and then you give me any value of x i
can just evaluate it
to figure out whether it is zero or not
okay
so uh and of course there are other
applications of boolean functional
synthesis
i'm not going to go over all of them for
lack of time
but uh you know for example certifying
qbf sat solvers
uh have a lot of applications and uh you
know the scolam functions we are talking
about
are of course certificates and it can be
used in program synthesis
uh repair of circuits and so on and so
forth
now for purposes of this talk i'm going
to focus
on a particular paradigm which is
you know really counterexample uh guided
repair
uh but i mean to sort of really give you
the full picture
uh there are three steps involved in it
you guess some candidates column
functions starting from
a boolean specification and then you
check
if your guess is correct or not
and if it is not you get a counter
example and then
you've got to repair the candidates
column functions based on this counter
example so this is the part on which
you know we want to focus a little bit
today uh and of course once you've
repaired uh
you can send back the repaired uh
scrolling functions and then
you can again check them and this loop
iterates
um you know as long as it is needed to
generate the correct column functions
and we will see that this loop must
always terminate because of the specific
way in which we repair
the candidate's column functions okay
so uh of course you know when i'm doing
this repair i need to know
a little bit about what are the things
that i am trying to repair so what is it
that i have guessed
so that i am going to try to repair
those and so towards
that end we are going to talk you know a
slide or two about the guesses
so that we are clear about what we are
trying to prepare
so uh in order to do this guess uh what
i'm going to do is i'm going to fix a
linear ordering of the outputs
uh let's say y1 through ym and uh
i'm going to you know instead of trying
to express
each of the outputs as functions of the
inputs x directly
i'm going to generate the last output
call it y m in terms of x and all the
previous outputs
so here i have shown the previous
outputs in blue
to intend to sort of suggest that i am
treating these
i mean these are really outputs of the
system but i want to treat these as
inputs
when i'm generating the last output so
that
you know from this specification x and y
1 through y m
i treat x and y 1 through y m minus 1 as
inputs
and i just generate y m in terms of this
now this is for the last output what
happens for the output prior to that
we say okay i'm going to generate y m
minus 1 in terms of
x and y 1 through y m minus 2 and what
will be the spec from which i want to
generate this
i want to basically quantify out y m i
want to say that look
you know this was my original
specification i don't want to bother
about ym
any further so i'm going to
extensionally quantify it and then i'm
going to
generate y minus 1 in terms of x and y 1
through y
minus 2. and if i continue this process
then you know at the end
i'll get y1 directly as a function of x
because by the time
all of the y through i m have already
been quantified
and this you know sounds like a
reasonable strategy except that uh
you know there are these two sub
problems that we have to solve
one is in each of these cases i'm
basically generating a scolum function
for
one output spec in each of these specs
there is a single output colored red
and then i need to compute these uh
you know existentially quantified
formulas i need to do the quantifier
elimination from this and this is
actually
of often quite hard to do these long
sequences of
existential quantification so what we'll
try to
work with are approximations of these
existentially quantified formulas
okay and then uh you know it is not very
hard to show that
if you are able to generate y1 through
ym
as these functions g1 through gm
then you can sort of stitch them
together
to generate the f1 to fm that you were
looking for
no remember that f1 to fm were only
functions of x
whereas this y1 through yn are functions
of x
and the other outputs in in the given
order
and so it can be shown that you know
there is
just a small blow-up in trying to go
from these functions to the original
functions
and therefore it makes sense to just
focus on
uh computing these functions g one
through g m
and which really involves solving these
two sub problems how do i generate a
scoring function for one output spec
and how do i compute the existentially
quantified
formula how do i do the quantifier
elimination or at least compute
approximations of that
okay now for the single output case it
actually turns out to be very easy i
mean if i have a single output i can
just set that output to one
and then i get a scrolling function or i
can set that output to zero and negate
and then i also get a scoring function
and there is you know a little bit of
uh sort of working out shows that this
indeed works so there is no guess work
involved
if there's a single output specification
i can generate it straight away
now there are multiple outputs then we
have seen that i need to quantify out
some of these variables and
you know this can be a sequence of
quantifications this is hard in general
but i can easily obtain approximations
of this quantification
if i start from the negation normal form
of the specification
and in fact as i'm just going to show
that you start from the negation normal
form of the specification
and if you set all the y i through y m
leaves and the negation y into negation
y m leads to 1
you get an over approximation of this
quantified formula and if you set the y
i through i am leaves and the negation y
attribution y m leads to zero
so this is kind of strange because i am
not treating y i and negation y i as
negations of each other i am setting
all of these leaves to one but it's okay
to do this if i have the n
f form of the formula and then this
gives the under approximation
and then i can use these under
approximations instead of the actual
existentially quantified formula
to guess the candidate functions gi
right and of course if i start with an
over approximation i'll get an over
approximation of the candidate function
if i start with an under approximation
i'll get the under approximations
i mean depending on which one of these
i'm using here starting with over
approximations i get over approximations
and here starting with the
approximations i get under
approximations so here is
just illustrating how this approximation
works here is a simple specification
has some inputs x and some outputs y
and i want to existentially quantify out
y1 and y2 so i've written out the nnf
tree
and then since i'm trying to quantify
out y1 and y2 i'm going to
label all the y1 negation y1 y2 negative
y2 leaves as zeros
and that will give me an under
approximation and if i label all of
these leaves as one and that will be an
over approximation
so this is not very difficult one just
needs to work out and
it's it follows from the monotonicity of
the operators
in the nf form and so you know this is
pretty much what we are saying so
now the question is that uh
you know now that i have obtained these
guests column functions
are they correct and if they are not
correct how do i repair them
so given these functions i need to check
whether
you know our definition of this column
function works
uh and it looks like we need a qbf
solver
but uh you know we sh we were able to
show that
uh you know one can really massage this
formula a little bit
and get a propositional formula which
involves two copies of the outputs
y and y prime and then if you feed this
propositional formula to a sat solver
then this propositional error formula is
unsatisfiable
if and only if the scoring functions the
guests column functions are correct
and if it is satisfiable it gives you a
satisfying assignment
which serves as a counter example to the
claim
that the the scolum functions you
guessed are correct
because if you get a satisfying
assignment what this is saying is that
for a given x there actually exists
some values of y which can make the
specification true
but if you set the y's to your column
functions
the specification evaluates to false so
clearly it means that there is an
error in the guest scoring function
somewhere
in in some of the scoring functions so
how do we repair
okay so uh
so you know the counter example that
comes out of this
uh sat call gives you
a specific valuation of uh the x's and
the y's
and you could say okay let me take those
specific valuations and let me say that
okay
for those specific valuations of x uh
the values of y should be different
but uh you know this is not very
efficient because
you know how many valuations of x it
could go all the way up to two rays to
the cardinality of x
so we want to generalize these counter
examples okay
we want to find out okay from a given
counter example can i find out
slightly more counter examples by
generalizing it such that
you know i can then use the generalized
counter example to repair
so in order to understand how this
generalized counter example is obtained
uh what we're going to do is we're going
to use these two quantities
uh delta i and gamma i which are under
approximations of these
existentially quantified formulas we
were looking at with 0 and 1 substituted
for
the i-th value of the variable now
remember
that we figured out that there is a way
to under approximate
uh the quantified formula and also to
over approximate the quantified formula
so here if i want an under approximation
of the negation of the quantified
formula
i should really be over approximating
the quantified formula which is setting
the corresponding leads to one
in the nnf form so i basically obtain
the over approximations of the
quantified formula negate them that
gives me under approximations of these
formulas
now why are we dealing with these delta
i's and gamma i's
it turns out that you know the guests
column functions
were really the delta i's and the
negation gamma i's remember we we said
that
this guest's column functions where just
the one output
specification case where you just either
set that output to one
and you know take the formula as is
which is the negation gamma i
which is you know these are quantified
and you just set the output to one
or you set the output to 0 and you
negate the specification which is
setting the output to 0
and taking delta i so all our guest
functions are either gamma i or delta i
for different i they could be different
and indeed uh
for uh the counter example uh you know
it
it sort of showed us that this guest
scoring functions are wrong
and so the generalization process what
it does
it says that okay let me find out a
function mu
in terms of x and y 1 through y j minus
1
for sum j remember this was the format
in which we were guessing the
scolum functions so let me find out
function mu
which generalizes sigma in the sense
that sigma
projected on these variables satisfies
mu and
mu also implies gamma j
and delta g remember we have all of
these gamma js and delta g's which are
under approximations of these quantities
and the moment i can find such a mu and
there are several heuristic ways to find
such a mu
we can immediately say that this mu
serves as a generalized counter example
for the guess column functions
and why is that because if you look at
the definition of gamma j and delta j
you will notice that if you conjoin them
you actually
you know basically you figure out that
there is no
way of setting values to y i through y m
which will make phi evaluate to true
right so gamma j and delta j implies
uh that for all values of yj through ym
negation phi will evaluate to true so
this means that there is something wrong
with the values that we have set
to g1 through gj minus 1 and no
satisfying assignment of mu
can be extended to satisfy 5. so
you know this is the core idea how we do
counter example guided refinement we
generalize
the counter example to get a mu and this
gives a problematic assignment for
g1 to gj minus one the guesses and then
i know that
at least one of these must be flipped
because the counter example generalized
is telling me that there is some problem
over here
and so what we do is we say okay let's
you know try to find the
smallest set j such that i have this mu
and then we flip gj minus 1 because if i
were to keep g1 to gj minus 2 unchanged
then indeed the value of gj minus 1 must
be flipped because i know that the
entire tuple of values from g1 to j
minus 1
is is wrong okay and what does this mean
that
if i had obtained gj minus 1 as negation
gamma j minus 1 remember all the guesses
were either negation gammas or deltas
then
i need to add the mu you know to this
comma j minus 1 and if if this was delta
j minus 1 i need to add it to delta j
minus 1.
so you know let me just wrap up by
saying that
uh you know this is the high level idea
of how we do counter example
guided repair and note that this really
involves
expanding these under approximations
gamma and delta
every counter example is generalized and
that the generalization is added
to these either the gamma or the delta
depending on
you know what was being used uh for gj
minus one
and so therefore we also call this
expansion based refinement
and this also gives us an easy argument
to say that why this must terminate
because these expansions cannot go on
forever right i mean these are
uh eventually under approximations of
some quantities and i'm adding more and
more
minterms to these quantities i will
eventually reach the under
i'll eventually reach the quantities
they were trying to under approximate
so uh you know for lack of time i'll
just show uh some results and then
take questions uh so we have implemented
this technique in this tool called
uh bfss for blazingly fast skolling
synthesis
and we have compared this uh with the
tool called cadet which is from
sanjits group and uh what we find is
that and kirit of course uses a
completely different
uh you know it uses it makes use of ccl
style reasoning
to solve the same problem and uh
you know what we find is that these two
approaches are kind of complementary to
each other
none subsumes other and so perhaps it's
best to put them in a portfolio solver
because you know places where cadet
doesn't work well vfss
with this counter example guided repair
works well and vice versa
and uh so with that i'd like to end
because i've already run out of time
and we have to take questions
thank you super thick um right on time
are there any questions from the
audience
okay let me start with a question of my
own so super thick uh
do you think uh the ideas that you
presented here can be lifted to
a quantified smt like quantified bit
vectors
um synthesizing scolum functions for
quantified smt formulas
uh yeah so uh so if you
i mean one a knife where not the nice
ways to blast the bit vectors and then
everything else here
but that's of course not the nice way so
uh for bit vectors
uh you know this problem that we said
solving for
one's colon right for one single output
i mean if we could if we could solve
this problem
so if we could solve this bit vector
problem for one
output and actually you know i think uh
a lot of the smt solvers actually have
instantiation schemes which allow you to
solve this
um cvc4 i think z3 all of them have
uh so it can
be bootstrapped based on the single
output solution and then trying to
quantify things out
but then you can work with under
approximations and over approximations
of those quantifications
so the short answer to your question is
yes
but we have not gone to the point of
building a tool which does it
okay and i'm sure you know there is a
lot of gap between theory and practice
when we try to solve such problems
so there are other things that are going
to show up right
so so so yes i guess in principle the
same techniques can be used
uh but because for the single output
case we could use quantify instantiation
techniques
to solve it and then we could use the
over approximations and under
approximations of the quantified
formulas
to solve for big vectors in fact this
strategy should work not just for with
vectors but for
any theory where you can solve these two
problems single out
scrolling synthesis you can solve and
you can get over and under
approximations of the
qualified formulas okay great yeah i
think i think that extension would be
really
uh useful for that some of the
applications you listed on the slide
like program synthesis for instance
right because just working at the bit
level is a little bit limiting
in that uh area absolutely fully i mean
yeah um so we started some work on it
but uh
you know we are i mean there's a lot
more as i said
there's a lot more between the theory
and the tool which we have to
sort of solve okay
any other questions
okay i don't see anything in the q a so
if there are questions please put them
in the chat or put them in the q a
uh so that super three can answer them
okay thank you again super thick
sure so uh that brings us to our
midpoint today uh